[Applaudissements]
je vais partir avec tout le public les
chéris on va partir tous ensemble
[Applaudissements]
on va parcourir les chéris on va partir
avec tout public les hameaux à ce que
vous voulez partir avec moi jusqu'à
demain
il a créé à partir de tuer les fuyards
de l'aider car années d'écart alléluia
des cartes mémoires et voilà
[Applaudissements]
les cherry on va partir avec tout le
public avec vous les chroniqueurs avec
tout le monde
mathieu martin avec nous on va partir et
on va partir pour une soirée de folie on
va faire la fête toute la nuit on va
vous montrer les images de mares va
faire la fête toute la nuit on va dormir
là bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu étais petit avantage